hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey
we're gonna watch today a video that's
almost a year old kima thrones infinity
war style boy one of our top award hears
on patreon but everybody who requested
miss definitely did put up on YouTube
today comes from the Canadian man
firefighter Lance Doric
so we're gonna do it today it's Darren
yeah what is he he's no nothing
so yeah he's in infinity
I thought she felt
the true enemy won't lay out stone
he brings the storm hey spider-man
badass think that's super afraid all
right
it's doom head yeah it's like so in
second conduct
oh I said
Running Shot where's there it is yeah
we're stuck who the hell are you guys
that was not the hello you guys and also
in a show that has so many swords and
shields how was there no line about
getting anyone a shield and he gets the
Spanish most iconic line that was really
well cut together for sure the more I
watched these the more we watched these
trailers in the style of other trailers
the more I'm starting to feel like okay
like the key to that Avengers infinity
war trailers for most of it they're
showing our ensemble reacting to the
change in tone yeah and then you know
they're slowly bringing in the more
sinister kind of devastating images and
then at the end you have a bad they also
cut the action beats together like the
famous like with the name mercy black
panther yeah yeah types of moments when
they shift to the fighting this trailer
also seems to fighting yeah and yeah the
king of the White Walkers is
this is really cool really well I didn't
especially because for kima throws you
so much to draw from and I know that you
know this is building up you know to the
Great Lord yeah so it's a lot of like
later footage but even still like it cut
together really nice Game of Thrones
lends itself really well to do and if
any were style trailer because of the
wide ensemble of cast and characters
spread out it's like even with the
opening before the HBO logo appears of
cutting to the characters and then not
using neither actual internal narration
or something like that because clearly
what they use in the infinity war one
was recorded for the trailer because
they're all same nick fury's line but
you know taking lines they've said and
then using that echo effect in order to
have the you know thoughts yeah it was
an internal narrative that's kind of
pertinent to the overall theme that's
going on here
and I guess it just makes you realize
that you know with the right music and
the right angles you could probably
infinity war just about it yes you know
cuz because it's so much of it
especially in the infinity war style is
just people reacting to stuff and kind
of looking dismay yeah especially with
this season where Game of Thrones is
headed in terms of like a whole bunch of
people who are divided separate people
who are not even really all that
necessarily linked of other the fat and
they're in the same universe in world
all having to come together to fight
against a common enemy a common
Universal threat
yeah the kaiju yeah really lends itself
well yeah and they get their giant
robots it's gonna be great like they
could have found some I mean I liked the
ending touch with the the night king at
the end they probably could have found
some type of line but in terms of rhythm
and beat and oh these this may be a
hidden weapon or something it's a
logical sting moment but yeah it doesn't
it doesn't have any of the humor at that
moment at the end of the Avengers
trailer does any happen to find the
perfect I was like there's plenty of
running shots in Game of Thrones but
which shot are they gonna use man plenty
of battles yeah so but the he found the
one shot where you got a specific group
of like five characters running away
from a giant storm of all the same thing
that's like John torrent or Mia the
difference the main difference is that's
an actual shot from the show
yeah it's not gonna be completely
removed and manipulated yeah this is
great
yeah thanks for showing this to us I
like I like watching these trailers in
the style of other trailers that we do
so many trailer reactions it's cool to
like actually break down how trailers
were edited and cut because there's an
art form to it yeah itself so yeah it's
where they're just taking the music and
you do find certain beats or a thematic
things and you do manipulate certain
footage elements yeah yeah I think it's
great it's like weirdly educational and
in a sense if you pay enough attention
cuz yeah it's like it's breaking down
the aesthetic approach of film
advertising those styles are so much of
what entices absolutely absolutely and I
gotta tell you guys there's Lance doors
birthday very recently Lance what he was
telling me was he went to Chicago yes
birthday was just on January 7 so just a
few weeks ago I tell you really enjoy
black clansmen I just throw that out
there his family I got him plane tickets
to Chicago and game tickets to the
Blackhawks versus Calgary Flames games I
just don't like his team one based off
what he said sorry man hey he's got
another vacation coming up in Europe in
July with his family so glance I sent
you a message recently just saying like
it's really cool to know a family man
like yourself I think a lot of the times
you guys that firefighter just is a
really loyal family man I'm a family guy
doesn't seem like oh that's a normal
thing to do and it is normal but it
doesn't make it any less special
and honestly meeting guys like you who
just have such a good heart and are
someone who you can consider to be just
a loyal person that is a special trait
and you have a job that is also
something that I think does go under
recognized no there's totally selfless
having you in our lives it's a really
special thing and thank you for being
such a hardcore supporter of us buddy we
love you man
and for sending us cool stuff like yeah
man you brought yes and subscribe to the
reject nation click that notification
bell and chicks on patreon we got plenty
of goodies sayonara Chiefs